les restrictions sanitaires sont petit à
petit levé et que la vaccination
s'accélère encore en france un débat
ressurgit faut-il vacciner les enfants
c'est normal le sont là pour atteindre
d'immunité collet qu'il faudrait sans
doute autorisé cette vaccination qui
fait peur à certains parents voyez pas
qu'un problème il ya de l'écho y'en a
pas un régime qu'ils ont dit oui en plus
beaux noms originaux tant qu'aide ça
passe veerappa il est con comme une
savane
ça fait quand même plusieurs années
comprenant ce moment les genres on le
voit il y avait alain fischer
mais bien à l'afficheur
[Rires]
on est bien l'équipe
voilà ce cancer se faire vacciner
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
phrasé n'est qu'à rencontre mandela
et qu'avez vous aurez des séries
mondiales
console l'échelle et le même schéma que
ça du gouvernement était sur france info
et leur application à maxime on aurait
quelques problèmes
regardez mon sac chapeau voilà les
effets secondaires